Vivek ramaswamy February 11 2021
4757 followers
I just grabbed a random date from a
couple years ago fast forward to
December 8th 2022 156
000 followers jump a few months ahead to
the to March 2023 364
000 followers and in less than a year he
has jumped to 1 million followers wow
this dude is
like you said he's running the campaign
Ron should have been running I don't
think I'm capable of anything remotely
close to this guy this guy's like a gem
he people like this don't appear all the
time and and most importantly Vivek I
think is actually campaigning for after
the election yeah he's never he can't
say it you know so when he was here I
was like I think you're not gonna I know
you're not gonna win and I think you
know you're not gonna win but you're
you're doing this anyway because there's
a lot more that comes with it it changes
the conversation you get on the debate
stage you can bring some issues to the
Forefront and he's like look look I'm
running to win yeah yeah but he's a
smart guy he knows